antoine bonjour alors de nombreux des
questions hier entre les trois
dirigeants que faut-il en retenir
et bien tout d'abord que le lien n'est
pas rompu les trois dirigeants
continuent de communiquer et c'est déjà
en soi très important surtout dans le
contexte particulièrement tendu de ces
dernières semaines entre la russie et
l'union européenne
d'autant que certains échanges ont été
productifs comme par exemple concernant
la lutte contre le coc vie 19 d'après le
kremlin les perspectives de
l'enregistrement du vaccin russe le
spoutnik v ont été évoquées tout comme
la possibilité de le livrer ou même
encore le produire conjointement au sein
de l'union européenne
il a également été question du cren
emmanuel macron et angela merkel ont
appelé au respect du cessez-le-feu et
réaffirmé leur détermination à voir les
accords de minsk appliquer tout comme
vladimir poutine d'ailleurs mais celui
ci regrette l'absence de dialogue direct
entre kiev et les dirigeants des
républiques autoproclamées de donetsk de
lougansk afin de réellement faire
avancer les choses
la situation en biélorussie en libye
mais aussi en syrie ont aussi été
abordées tout comme l'état de santé d'un
alexeï navalni incarcéré depuis
maintenant un mois
merci beaucoup à vous antoine gayraud
pour toutes ces précisions en direct
depuis moscou